welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and somebody once told me that there was
a wee bit of chaos inside of steven
grant in marvel's first trailer for the
upcoming incredible dopeness that is
soon to be moon night on disneyplus.com
i mean i'm not sure if you caught some
of oscar isaac's chaotic energy during
those few minutes during that trailer
because apparently steve here is about
to play consu's clues just to find out
that he's not even a steve at all but
instead mark spector a dude playing a
dude disguised as another dude but
though that new trailer has all of us
nerds over the moon with all of exciting
moments of moon mystery ethan hawk's
line at the end telling mark to embrace
the chaos might actually be a really big
and subtle hint as to what's to come in
this series as i believe that moon
knight could actually directly link to
the very chaos of the upcoming doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness a
movie set to drop only two moons after
moon night's season finale which is kind
of suspicious don't you think so let's
speculate how right now my beautiful
nerd baby cows because we jumping over
the moon of speculation because i
suspect mark spector to be under a
similar type of dark magic influence
like one wicked wanda dude where's my
sons maximuff at the end of one division
and i believe the key to mark's madness
lies directly within the crescent-shaped
artifact that lies at the center of moon
knight's chest and front and center on
the first official poster for the show
because much like the ten rings acted as
a bridge for the dweller in darkness to
mess with wenwu's mind this
crescent-shaped object will seek to do
the same with mark spector's mind
specifically by acting as an alien
source of red cosmic chaos darkness
energy that predates the birth of the
light in the mcu you know the dark times
where the dark elves existed in the dark
world because much like i outlined
within the marvel trigger theory in the
video about like the no way home purple
cracks that i highly recommend that
everybody watch because it basically
explains the entire science behind all
the infinity stones in the mcu you're
welcome
i highly suspect mcu chaos magic if
you're a wizard or chaos energy if
you're a reed richards is tied to the
red dark chaotic ether of the mcu the
reality stone because guess what
everybody the mcu ether is based on the
old debunked astronaut theory of a
little thing called the luminiferous
ether which is basically what confused
space nerds back in the day thought that
light particles traveled on in the
vacuum of space because you know if
boats and waves in the ocean interact
with water particles and we smell a
fresh fart because fart particles
interact with air particles what the
hell is causing photons to travel in the
dark vacuum of space the luminiferous
ether of course or so they thought but
anyways this is a massively important
part of what chaos magic is because once
you understand this you'll be able to
understand what is possibly going on
within mark spector's mind and his
multiple personalities while also
beginning to understand wanda and
vision's special cosmic connection
because from wanda's introduction in age
of ultron we learned from maria hill
that wanda maximoff's chaos magic allows
her to do neuroelectric interfacing and
mental manipulation her thing is
neuroelectric interfacing telekinesis
mental manipulation and this means that
through wanda's mastery of the red
luminiferous ether that was everywhere
before the birth of the light in the mcu
wanda can use that luminiferous ether to
read feel and manipulate photons and
electricity in other light matter which
is why she is able to read both tony
stark and ultron vision's brain waves in
age of ultron and why wanda tells vision
that she only feels him in infinity war
because she only feels his mind stone
singularity which is the singularity of
atomic mastery go watch the marvel
trigger video it's all up like all the
stuff all the science explanations of
the infinity stone is in that video it's
my proudest video i've ever made go
watch that anyway all of this works
because chaos magic is that luminiferous
ether darkness that all of the light of
the mcu sits on and can be manipulated
by because as we all know despite being
a fundamental part of our universe light
and darkness do not mix like darkness
absorbs light but all the light matter
that otherwise planets are made out of
and all the suns in the universe sit on
the darkness of the ether the
luminorphus ether in the mcu it's not
real in real life we all love the
escapism of fictional universes but
sometimes that escapism is a little bit
more urgent because zombie hordes are
trying to eat our brains because thanks
to this video sponsor undead world hero
survival it has truly never been more
fun to survive the zombie apocalypse you
collect equip and upgrade a squad of
heroes for zombie battle join a guild to
participate in raids and earn rewards
battle other players in the arena
including the raging rumble exclusively
for high ranking heroes and they're
always adding new heroes features and
events explore the new special operation
zones to play battlefield where each
stage has a trial to overcome and gather
the right squad to survive to win it all
there's a new year's challenge running
through january 23rd where you can
complete missions to earn rewards there
are over a dozen daily and event
missions players can complete to earn
rewards i really like the zombie express
game mode like you're on the top of a
train with waves of zombies coming at
you and you see how long your heroes can
survive not very long probably and new
players can get 1 000 free diamonds plus
if you download and play undead world
hero survival using the link below or by
scanning the qr code you see on this
screen and entering the promo code new
rockstars 500 you yes you can get an
additional 500 free diamonds this all
being said i have a hunch that after
mark spector has his life saved by
konshu at the foot of the statue of
kanchu much like his origins are in the
comics mark then steals the very
crescent off of the statue of konshu
itself not knowing that kantu's
concentrated dark chaos magic lives deep
within the artifact chaos magic that
begins to seep deep within mark
spector's brain and starts manipulating
the bioelectric energy in there
basically changing his brain current
flow to override mark with a completely
different personality kind of like what
rwanda did to the people of west view
with her chaos energy powers because i
really do believe that this moon knight
crescent will be the mcu's adaptation of
the statue of konshu's sapphire crescent
in the comics and the very source of
moon knight's konshu chaos power because
at the end of the day all we are as
people are just brainwaves and
electrical signals so if that crescent
that mark possesses is a source of
foreign dark chaos energy then i can
very much see this artifact being
exactly how the dark god conscious
creates all of his super loyal looter
lunatics throughout time by basically
hijacking their biological computers
with chaos energy and overriding them
with the moon knight matrix essentially
in fact and this is kind of a little bit
extra here i think that the mcu has been
teasing this on multiple levels because
i have this weird feeling that molina's
red black widow mind control juice could
have its roots within this neural
electrical chaos energy science as well
but that's just an extra thing and i
guess by extension the winter soldier
project because hydra was involved with
both and since the mcu has pretty much
been reliably using red to denote
darkness within the background since as
early as 4-2 this could explain why the
tips of this mysteriously carved moon
knight crescent has red on it in the
poster i mean because yeah obviously
it's supposed to imply that there's
blood on it but i can also see marvel
studios using this imagery to secretly
point towards the hidden chaos within
the ancient alien artifact imbued with
dark power and one that mcu blade will
undoubtedly come to collect much like
the ebony blade due to its destructive
nature within our universe of light i
think that this crescent is straight up
just a high concentration of konchu
chaos magic packaged within a crescent
moon shaped dark matter artifact you
know the same type of foreign metal
malekith's daggers are made out of
because as far as i can see the mcu is
very much moving in the direction of
telling us the story of the dark and the
damned of the mcu with the dark book of
the damned the darkhold kicking us off
in the one division finale the ten rings
in the dweller in darkness teasing us
more in chiang chi and of course dane
whitman's dark blade of the damned the
ebony blade being the latest dark world
artifact in the eternal's post-credits
scene but unfortunately for mark spector
he didn't have blade to stop him from
touching the metaphorical butt and
getting mooned by the powerful godlike
alien entity konchu who i suspect to
live on the very far reaches of the mcu
universe where the light of the big bang
does not touch because the celestials
haven't gotten to that part yet you know
where the rest of the weird mythical
creatures of the mcu that strange
supreme can summon with this red chaos
magic in that episode of what if
basically what i'm saying is if there is
an mcu mephisto he definitely comes from
this dark edge of the mcu universe but
that's just what i think do you think
that chaos magic could be in play in
moonlight's mind let us know below my
beautiful speculation nation nerd babies
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video be sure to follow me
at mastertainment on twitter if you want
to see me tweet some weird and
really weird theories follow new rock
stars wherever we are on the internet
especially on youtube and when you do on
youtube make sure you hit that
notification bell so you get
notifications every time we upload a
video and be sure to hit up your
rockstarsmerch.com you can get a cool
shirt like this thanks again so much for
watching i'll see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you